what are you waiting for douchebag that
guy's just getting there go kick his ass
hey youtubers is charlie and since I'm
planning on doing a whole bunch of
southpark stick of truth videos I wanted
to do an in-depth preview the game and
give you an idea for what some of those
videos are going to look like a lot of
it'll just depend on what you guys want
to see but I'm also giving away 2 $20
steam gift cards it's going to be a
random selection all you have to do is
be a subscriber and leave a comment but
I'll pick the winners next week on to
the fun stuff this video will just be a
straight-up preview of the game with
details and background on the mechanics
the next video I do will be an early
review on launch day on march seven it's
going to be on 360 ps3 and pc but i'll
be playing the pc version just because
it's easier to do game capture after
that i'll do a mixture of let's play
videos with another review too as i plow
through the game I can also do
walkthroughs if you guys want in the
past I haven't done a lot of video game
stuff just because my real-life job is
full time and I'd like to sleep but if I
were ever to pull all-nighters it would
have to be for something that was either
really fun or really important and I
know stick of truth is at least going to
be a ton of fun important thing to note
if you are a UK gamer and you're playing
the console version of the game you will
be playing something different from all
the rest of us in the UK it got censored
in about 7 cut scenes that were 20
seconds long each were cut mostly on
account of extreme awesomeness so all
you have to do if you want the
uncensored version is by the pc version
via steam or somewhere else the game is
like the next best thing to a 50 hour
long south park episode so even if
you're not a gamer i would recommend
buying it just look at some of these
ridiculous xbox achievements KKK let
gingers bite you three times without
blocking fling a turd that you created
at an enemy in combat the list gets even
crazier your pants in battle three
times that is a whole lot of poop but
the visual look and the mechanics are
also really cool too for nintendo fans
it looks a lot like Paper Mario with
every south park reference you could
ever think of the story does have a
loose narrative and the battles are done
JRPG turn-based style but like most
western RPG games the achievements and
missions our exploration based so you
can complete a lot of the game out of
order if you've ever played Warcraft or
any other
based MMO you will have a pretty easy
time with the battles there is a
strategy element in defeating groups as
you know you have to kind of make the
call of the target dps base classes like
mages before you can deal with melee
class NPCs the actual playable classes
are thief warrior mage and jus the death
mechanics are also really funny too if
you go to heaven you're greeted by a
bunch of Mormons just like on the series
and as you level up NPCs get a lot more
interesting like eventually you might
find yourself fighting a herd of
Mongolians on horseback goddamn
Mongolians some of the attack bonuses
and damage modifiers get really funny to
like protect my balls I've always been
biased towards RPG games in general
mostly JRPG games but I'm a big south
park fan and I can't think of a better
way to waste my life and have fun at the
same time if you've seen any of the
breakdown or easter egg videos i do i
might include some of that stuff in a
walkthrough video mostly I'm just
looking forward to putting myself inside
a 50-hour plus South Park episode 50
hours is kind of the benchmark for most
RPG games like Skyrim if you only play
the main storyline and mandatory quests
if you do all the side quests I'm sure
you could stretch stick of truth all the
way to 120 plus hours for anyone out
there that's a complete is I am
something of an achievement myself
too so I won't start playing till actual
launch date on the seventh but my Steam
Community profile is just emergency
awesome be sure to let me know what kind
of videos you want to see for me for
this you know either let's play
walkthroughs or just game reviews right
now click here to learn about my top 5
anime villains and click here to get my
preview for guardians of the galaxy
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives